bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time we're back you know the Jadakiss on
we're back in the land of good lighting
and good Wi-Fi in New York City what's
up while officers trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right big facts
don't forget what he's now sponsored by
block Phi they've got three parks you
can go buy and sell crypto you can give
them crypto and they'll give you a u.s.
dollar loan or my favorite product as an
investor and the user is you can deposit
crypto or a digital dollar and you could
earn up to eight point six percent ap
why they pay you every first Monday of
the month call it black 5 Mondays I love
it
black fight a cops us lunch money what's
up how are you why do you have a blue
dress on that looks like you're in an
aquarium it does not look like I'm in an
aquarium but it's like a modern version
of Ariel from The Little Mermaid
it's erielle who is he real it's
definitely not Ariel okay are you
talking about it's not how you pronounce
your name arial 'arial arial 'arial no
it's not she she's not flying through
the air doing an aerial stunt it's area
uber agrees to buy food delivery service
post mates for 2.65 billion in stock
first of all you are you are the expert
good deal bad deal okay so I think for
post mates like Lord bless your souls
because post mates has been trying to go
or has been saying they're going public
every year for the last few years
finally somebody bought them for 2.7
billion dollars in stock so good for you
post mates cuz lord knows you're going
get hold on back up for a second post
mates is a food delivery service in the
United States are the fourth largest on
a market share standpoint there's Thor -
then there's a burger Bob and then
there's post mates uber previously tried
to buy grub hub grub hub got acquired
though a couple of weeks ago by just eat
takeout calm which is a company in
Europe they got bought for seven point
six billion dollars and then now post
mates is getting inquired by uber for
2.6 billion interesting all-stock deal
no cash to its at a flat valuation to
the last fund raised round in September
of 2019 where they raised two hundred
twenty five million dollars at a two
point four billion dollar pre money and
third it actually appears like post
mates market share has been declining
over the last few weeks or months
because previously around January
February was reporting in about ten
percent market share in May they were
only eight percent of all US food
delivery so why are they doing this uber
their ride - hailing businesses going
down 80 plus percent down from the
pandemic it's now kind of risen a little
bit some people are saying is between
sixty is seventy percent down from the
peak so what they got to do they're
gonna double and triple down on food
delivery and hopefully save the company
with the ciliary okay so in 2018 in
September I wrote an article about post
mates raising I think 300 million
dollars after it claimed that you know I
really wanted to go public
and there were some rumors that it was
gonna merge or it was gonna get bought
and here's what the CEO told me yeah he
insisted he was serious about a 2019 IPO
he said listen I'm an immigrant and I
came to this country to launch the
postman's business my dream is to run a
publicly traded company has his dream
gone to hell now or do you think he's
happy with the 2.65 of the stock
billions
well first of all I don't think this is
a great deal for investors that at least
invest in the last round the executives
will be fine but they're gonna merge the
post mates business with the uber eats
business but it's going to be run that
division of the coming to be run by the
guy who's running Hoover eats now let's
getting recently took over for the guy
who originally launched the who breeds
business who left the company what's
gonna happen to the CEO there's like no
mention of him anywhere
post meets I mean he'll probably work at
the company for a little bit 12 to 24
months I hope you become public company
see what's going on with Warren Buffett
what's going on with Warren Buffett who
lost his touch sold the bottom literally
panics sold the bottom what's he doing
he did it's a fact he literally held
airline stocks and right at the bottom
of the market sold all his airline
stocks like ultimate FOMO of a retail
investor one of the Great's probably the
best investor of all time sold the
bottom bad timing
what's going on with him I just I just
stared at the camera and didn't say a
word to see how you would keep going
because I was waiting for you to talk
Warren Buffett's Berkshire Hathaway buys
Dominion energy natural gas assets in a
ten billion dollar deal there's a bigger
deal than uber post mates it's not a big
deal why well it's a big deal yes it is
it's four times bigger than the post
meet steel but it's not a big deal for
Warren Buffett it's less than 10% of the
cash he has on hand it's a lot is it
it's like 7 to 8 percent of his cash but
why was he right there in the article
137 billion dollars of cash like I read
the Internet I got a memory of here
why is he doing that well basically what
his whole strategy is he buys things
that he thinks are cheaper than what
they're worth and so he obviously
that Dominion energy assets are much
cheaper than because of the mimic what
do you mean
they're cheaper because of the pandemic
of course right you remember the energy
industry got absolutely annihilated but
but some of it was pandemic related some
of it wasn't so you had a couple of
forces at play the first is that global
demand for energy in general drastically
dropped especially for oil gasoline etc
and because people aren't traveling that
you know all the reasons that we talked
about a million times and when that
happened then the market was flooded
with all sorts of oil and energy from
Russia and Saudi Arabia that drove
prices down right and now you get into a
situation where us especially the shale
oil producers but also other energy
producers they're coming under pressure
and ultimately what we're seeing is this
is what happens when an industry dies
right it's a really really slow death no
look that the energy industry is not
going anywhere in the short term and
probably not even in the medium term and
actually there will be some companies
that persist for a hundred years but
ultimately what ends up happening is we
are moving towards an electric future
you see that with cars you're gonna see
with other things and so the writing's
on the wall of where the kind of macro
trends are going the big question is
just how much value can be taken out of
the companies that currently exists
today in traditional energy - is wood or
the kind of inflection points that would
drive adoption of the electric future
and then the third thing is like where
do you want to play do you basically
want to play betting against change or
do you want to bet on change right so
really it comes down to people like
Warren Buffett they actually tend to bet
on things are not going to change more
so than they bet on technology and
innovation and things changing right
makes sense yes we buy energy essence I
still like Warren look boy I'm a huge
fan like he's the greatest investor for
sure more lifetimes right but it's just
that like at some point you start to
lose your touch and when you're in your
90s or you could own late 80s you're
probably not as sharp as you were in
your 30s or you could argue because he's
90 he has all the experience therefore
that makes him the best what do I know
though
okay but the facts show he literally
sold the bot okay stocks going down he
panicked he sold and then they recovered
if he had just held for another couple
of weeks and then sold it got a position
he didn't find maybe he has a strategy
you don't understand or know about what
he's doing
nobody cares okay back same deal okay do
you guys remember in an old lunch money
we talked about the drama around the
vaccines where Sanofi which is theirs
yeah I think that's how you pronounce it
Sanofi is this like vaccine giant
because the US government invested in
the company they said that they would
when they created all the us our
Americans would get the vaccine first in
the French government was like what the
hell and they're like what it you didn't
invest in us so anyway that's kind of
unrelated but GlaxoSmithKline and Sanofi
are partnering to develop a potential
coronavirus vaccine and they are
discussing a 500 million dollar pound
deal to supply the UK government with
the shot what is your complaint
so my complaint is i thought they were
giving it to americans first why are
they giving us a new one oh what
happened the old one is Piatt doesn't
work the one that doesn't work no at the
end of the day it's all corporate
bureaucracy it's all inside or nonsense
what you are having is you're literally
having government's pay these private
companies ridiculousness
hundreds of millions of dollars each
government is giving them in order to
develop this vaccine and then they're
trying to jockey for who gets it first
who doesn't whatever at the end of the
day you want to know who the winners of
all this is me know the executives of
the largest drug companies the lawyers
and the deal teams for large drug
companies and at some level there will
be winners at the government level as
well because I promise you there's some
government officials somewhere who today
works for the French government the UK
government the American government
whatever and within five years while all
of a sudden show up and they will be on
the GlaxoSmithKline
or
Sanofi Board of Directors Board of
Advisors on the executive team running a
division whatever so what we're seeing
is literally this is the collective
craxi all right kleptocracy I didn't say
that right it's okay
basically what ends up happening is all
they're doing is they're just
circulating money around at a time where
there's a crisis and they're trying to
leverage the fact that hey if I just
slosh around hundreds of millions of
dollars somehow somebody's gonna fall in
my pocket mmm you know who doesn't do
that just washing around who Arielle
okay Brock Pierce is jumping into the
2020 u.s. presidential election at the
last minute yes the crypto person broth
Pierce is saying that he is going to run
for president I'm sorry what a lot of
people are not gonna like this I don't
get it you don't get what I don't get it
cuz you would never run for president no
I just it's publicity he wants attention
yeah I mean it I don't get it hey Brock
here's some running for president Barack
once he was super nice to me no issues
with Brock I think that Brock again he
was incredibly kind we probably thought
for five minutes max that's all I've
know about him but I just what I say I
don't get it I don't get him Kanye West
as well and now he's gonna run for
president the timing it right now
announcing to run for president right I
can't make an evaluation on he's Brock
being serious is Kanye being serious are
they not being serious are different
listen II like I don't know I don't know
what his intentions are I don't get the
timing because as of right now you can't
even get your name on the ballot in a
number of states because we're too late
in the process so it's it's almost like
you know it's all you're trying to lose
but just the system of the or the
structure of the system is set up
against you because if you can get your
name on the ballot
then you would have to get written into
the ballot which drastically reduces the
opportunity for you to get votes so it's
just like I don't get the tiny is what I
mean by it right yeah it just seems like
it's a little late in the game but hey
supported
ah cracy people want to run for
president knock yourself out
I just wished that greeting has a better
shot of winning Brock Pearson said I
just wish that I could run for president
why can't you because I'm not belong
here that's a good rule or Dumble I'm
gonna kind of get it like I was talking
my friend Rihanna and she was like I
kind of get it because you know if
you're not born here there's like
questions about your loyalty but I will
say immigrants are much more loyal than
Americans sometimes like I don't know I
know some really patriotic immigrants
and when you weave a little American
flag and like renounce your other
citizenship and I'm like whoa you didn't
yeah I did you have to you have to like
at the ceremony and whatever but I think
some countries allow you to oh did you
keep citizenship I I think you can't
are you a dual citizen I actually don't
know because I haven't renewed my
anything in Bulgaria but like I think I
am okay I think if I want to be who do
you think is a better standing Rock
fiercer Kanye West Kanye would you vote
for Kanye yes okay wait wait I would
vote for Kanye under the condition that
his vice president is Elon Musk
it wasn't that rumor Elon Musk
first of all candy buddies oh that's
right we dig in no you can't he's not
born but I think vice president no
because you're the next in command to be
first of all second of all you know musk
would never do it third of all you would
really vote for Kanye West over my
current options yes to be clear Kanye
West would produce bangers in the White
House he would turn the White House into
the hottest nightclub in the world and
Anthony made the bold claim that he
thinks a Kim Kardashian would be vice
president or be that she would at some
point be the first female president what
my argument is is right now given all of
the options on the table if you said to
me make a bet on who will be the first
female president of the United States
you have to
have to whether you like it or not put
Kim Kardashian in the top three option
shocking here's why here's my argument
again I don't think that she one is
prepared to do the job
- I wouldn't vote for as of right now
and three is I'm merely saying it's more
of a claim of there's not a lot of great
candidates that have a legitimate shot
of winning just because of popularity of
course
so one we're entering has phase where
it's gonna be a popularity contest -
she's one of the most recognizable
people in the world three whether we
like it or not I personally believe that
the the person that ends up being the
first female president is going to have
to have a base of people who want a
female president he's gonna have to have
a base of people who believe in their
policies their beliefs all that kind of
stuff and then the third thing is I
honestly believe that physical looks we
know it already happens in male
elections
well we know in male elections it
matters right the whole idea of the
largest male there studies that show
whoever looks the most physically
dominating ends up actually human nature
the hump is six for six
he's wildly unattractive so that's what
your true it's not it's not about
attractiveness for males by the way John
F Kennedy I would argue probably had a
pretty good shot up being president
because people thought he was attractive
it doesn't you don't get to be president
because of it but it doesn't hurt your
chances if you're more attractive than
your opponent all right well in that
case I don't know how tall Brock
Pierce's I met him alright I saw him in
Vegas once I don't think he's very
dominant so I don't think his chances
yeah and neuters kind of like kind of I
think it's like 510 probably my point
just being that Kim Kardashian it's not
that I think Kim Kardashian is going to
be President or whatever but what we
were talking about is if you look at the
lay of the land if I named right now
potential female candidates tuna to be
president I would put in the top three
AOC Ivanka Trump and Kim Kardashian and
I actually believe out of those three
that Kim Kardashian would have the best
chance of winning in the next
twenty years and it all comes down to it
becomes a popularity contest and it
becomes about awareness and people are
fed up with the institution's the idea
that we have two people over the age of
seventy years old that we have to choose
from for president there's a lot of
people are saying that's crazy that's
crazy I think one of the questions
before you are allowed to run for
president should be do you or do you not
know what tick tock is if you don't know
you cannot run bring the age so way down
yeah Chuck is a massive cultural
influence and they have no idea what it
is agreed but again I think that there's
and by the way the whole Kim Kardashian
thing just to close that out is she's
making a massive push into doing things
like criminal reform criminal justice
reform and things like that and becoming
much more serious very hard to do we'll
see what happens I do not believe that
she will actually be President but I
think she has a shot I'm still holding
out for the wait okay the rock baby do
you think that anyone in this world can
be a good president if they surround
themselves with the right team because
they feel like yes my art has always
been my argument is that the president
actually can't create that much damage
they can do you know they can do a lot
of things but because of the checks and
balances and the democracy of the United
States the president actually has much
less power than we think that they do
and perfect example is if you look at a
number of things that both President
Trump and President Obama there are two
highly controversial Care characters I
end up being put into the office because
the other side of the political spectrum
absolutely hated them right both of them
did a lot of things by executive order
which is the ultimate power of a
president to say I want to do something
I'm gonna do it but the checks and
balances ended up actually kind of
coming out so like a good example was
Trump did travel ban but then ended up
getting blocked by the courts right
Obama similar situation did a lot of
things got blocked by courts so the
checks and balances in the United States
ends up reducing the power of the
present great I'm glad we have solved
the world issues would you vote for the
wrong or Kim Kardashian oh come on
okay New York real estate by the way
just so everyone knows Polina says she
would vote for Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian Ryan Seacrest
we always think prices in New York City
fallen sharply since the corona virus
pandemic shut the city down the number
of sales in Manhattan dropped 54% in the
median price fall to 1 million I mean
that still sounds like a lot of money to
me but what do I do
Dole I dia is just look people are
leaving New York City supply and demand
happens there's two things actually that
happened one is there's people leaving
but also two is people forget there was
incredible capital inflows in New York
from international investors basically
leading up I think it peaked in 2018 and
so when developers saw oh here comes all
of this international capital inflow
they were like let's build let's build
let's build so I started building like
crazy and what they did was they flooded
the market with all this inventory and
now people are caught with very tons of
inventory and actually they saw a peak
in the investor interest internationally
and now it's dropped and so literally
you've got international capital not
showing up and you have people leaving
and so therefore you get a drop in
demand and while supplies increasing
ends up leading the prices happening
we're still here so all is good oh wow
we're out of time
all right what's up with the lunch money
winner lunch money winner we asked you
guys to submit a joke to Twitter in
hashtag lunch money and Jimmy someone
Hong said my favorite joke what did the
fish say when it hit the wall damn
[Laughter]
that's pretty good Jimmy liked that one
a lot yeah you go Jimmy we've dmg your
hundred bucks is on the way it's that
we're a little rusty what do you mean
like you know we're like shaking off the
cobwebs from the weekend right we got
you know we had to get on what's money
going are you ready for my Juke yeah
what's your joke what concert costs
oh good he sighed now he's gonna guess
it oh no I really didn't see that
promise what concert costs just 45 cents
what concert yeah 45 cents he saw it
guys no I really didn't I promise I
don't know something like the penny
something or the double nickel nickel
bag a nickel back you saw it I swear to
God I did is it nickel back know what
else know five cents
tell me 50 cent featuring Nickelback ah
your boy was close oh it is there
whatever that's fine that's it for lunch
money today guys while while she's
trying to get rich dressed of us just
trying to get our lunch money right
look fourth of July cobwebs today sorry
we weren't as funny as usual have a
Larry I have pleaded with me she kind of
drags down my humor sometimes it's
alright we'll be better tomorrow
if I survive hope I don't get my ass
whooped between now and then kid show
see you guys tomorrow
yeah messages for the people be kind be
kind bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did don't
forget lunch money's now sponsored by
block 5 so go check them out there's a
link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy plan in the
comment and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends